another spectacular day for baseball in
pittsburgh
and today we play two it's the pirates
and the cincinnati reds the first of a
double header the start of a four game
series against the red lakes
if you can lay off he will throw balls
out of the zone the biggest issue for
most of red's hitters is when he walks
guys early in the inning
and he gets guys aboard some of those
pitcher
some of those pitches look like they're
a little more enticing when you're
trying to drive in a run matt davidson
now
and might have gotten a piece of brawl
turns out to be a routine double play to
end the top of the first
luis castillo still seeking victory
number one on the season
the era is over four but run support has
not been there as we documented
in the open and castillo ahead no balls
and two strikes
seven starts for castillo goes back to
it and his first punch out here in the
afternoon
that downward action is the major key
for the swing and miss of castillo
192 batting average it's kind of head
heading towards average there's a nice
little
change of pace there from braul you see
the change up
nice presentation by jacob stallings
first strikeout for brawl here is jesse
winker
nice work we're all back-to-back
strikeouts
i like to see brawl get ahead finish
guys and
wasting no time that slider first and
second two outs
for the red legs jose garcia into left
field that's a base hit they're gonna
wave around the runner
and the reds have a one-nothing lead the
rookie jose garcia his first
major league rbi and a breaking ball in
the middle of the zone
and garcia he made it hurt
and the batter is gregory polanco
and then he can line it to right and
this is going to be
oh off the glove of castillanos
froze for a moment so polanco will wind
up at second
and moran to third a nice swing there
from gregory polanco
uh i don't know if he got the barrel to
it or not but he hit it hard enough to
fool
castellanos right-handed hitter hayes
waiting on castilla
grounded to third they've got the runner
hung up to casalli
and he will tag out moran nice job
defensively by the reds
and that's a large out get the ball home
especially on the corners and suarez
does exactly that
12 men scoring position and the pirates
will shift around to the pool
side for suarez a big chance for a eu
haneo
in the air to ride plenty deep enough
to get the runner home from third
tagging up and scoring his
vato and the reds have a two nothing
lead it is rbi number 20 here in
2020 two outs the batter jesse winker
who's down to get it long run
and it's going to fall and this will
score castillano's
three nothing reds thank you very much
tucker playing deep had a long way to
come to get the baseball gonzalez
didn't look like he wanted to catch it
at all callings above 300
average on the season but not this time
second strikeout for castillo
he's about to shadow box these boys to
death i think man
now the pirates have two on with two out
and the batter is colin moran
bounced into the hole and that will
score gonzalez
colin moran two for two pirates on the
board
first and third polanco hits this one
well toward left center field then this
is gonna
split the gap and bounce over the wall
that's a bad break for the pirates they
get one
when you've got a guy throwing 99 miles
per hour like castillo is
you shorten up your swing to get to it
and look how far he hit that ball the
other way on a fastball
in first and second nobody out jacob
stallings
a one-two pitch foul tip into the middle
of casalli and it's a big
out take that for castillo
singleton scored in the third flew out
to right his first time up
[Music]
castianos left center field deepest part
of the park goodbye
into the reds bullpen so the magic
continues
for two rats 11th home run of the season
for nick castellanos
see the teamwork a little bit of height
yep one on two out
cole tucker now standing in strike three
called
castillo six innings of two-run baseball
now the pirates down to their final out
0-2 pitch
swing and a miss he indeed
struck him out and the reds take game
one of the doubleheader 4-2
your final score fifth save of the
season for reisel iglesias